I've been working in AI
for most of my career,
helping companies build
artificial intelligence capabilities
to improve their business,
which is why I think
what I'm about to tell you
is quite shocking.
Every year, thousands
of companies across the world
spend collectively tens of billions
of dollars to build AI capabilities.
But according to research
my colleagues and I have done,
only about 10 percent of these companies
get any meaningful financial impact
from their investments.
These 10 percent winners
with AI have a secret.
And their secret is not about fancy
algorithms or sophisticated technology.
It's something far more basic.
It's how they get their people
and AI to work together.
Together, not against each other,
not instead of each other.
Together in a mutually
beneficial relationship.
Unfortunately, when most people
think about AI,
they think about the most extreme cases.
That AI is here only to replace us
or overtake our intelligence
and make us unnecessary.
But what I'm saying
is that we don't seem to quite appreciate
the huge opportunity that exists
in the middle ground,
where humans and AI come together
to achieve outcomes that neither one
could do alone on their own.
Consider the game of chess.
You probably knew that AI today
can beat any human grandmaster.
But did you know that the combination
of a human chess player and AI
can beat not only any human
but also any machine.
The combination is much more powerful
than the sum of its parts.
In a perfect combination,
AI will do what it does best,
which is dealing with massive amounts
of data and solving complex problems.
And humans do what we do best
using our creativity, our judgment,
our empathy, our ethics
and our ability to compromise.
For several years,
my colleagues and I have studied
and worked with hundreds
of winning companies
who are successfully building
these human-AI relationships.
And what we've seen is quite interesting.
First of all, these companies get
five times more financial value
than companies who use AI
only to replace people.
Most importantly,
they have a happier workforce.
Their employees are more
proud, more fulfilled,
they collaborate better with each other,
and they're more effective.
Five times more value
and a happier workforce.
So the question is,
how do these companies do it?
How do they achieve these symbiotic
human-AI relationships?
I have some answers.
First of all, they don't think of AI
in the most extreme case
only to replace humans.
Instead, they look deep
inside their organizations
and at the various roles
their people play.
And they ask:
How can AI make our people
more fulfilled, more effective,
more amplified?
Let me give you an example.
Humana is a health care
company here in the US.
It has pharmacy call centers
where pharmacists work with patients
over the phone.
It's a job that requires a fair amount
of empathy and humanity.
Humana has developed an AI system
that listens to the
pharmacists' conversation
and picks up emotional and tone signals
and then gives real-time
suggestions to the pharmacists
on how to improve the quality
of that conversation.
For example, it might say
“Slow down” or “Pause”
or "Hey, consider how the other person
is feeling right now."
All to improve the quality
of that conversation.
I'm pretty sure my wife
would buy me one of these if she could,
just to help me in some
of my conversations with her.
(Laughter)
Turns out the pharmacists
like it quite a lot, too.
They're more effective in their jobs,
but they also learn something
about themselves,
their own behaviors and biases.
The result has been
more effective pharmacists
and much higher customer
satisfaction scores.
Now, this is just one example of many
possibilities where human AI collaborate.
In this example, AI was a recommender.
It didn't replace the human
or make any decisions of its own.
It simply made suggestions,
and it was up to the person
to decide and act.
And at the heart of it is a feedback loop,
which, by the way, is very critical
for any human-AI relationship.
By that I mean that in this example,
first AI had to learn from humans
the qualities that would make up a good
or not so good conversation.
And then over time,
as AI built more intelligence,
it would be able to make suggestions,
but it would be up to the person
to decide and act.
And if they didn't agree
with the recommendation
because it might have not
made sense to them,
they didn't have to.
In which case AI might learn something
and adapt for the future.
It's basically open, frequent,
two-way communication,
like any couples therapist will tell you,
is very important for any
good relationship.
Now the key word here is relationship.
Think about your own personal
relationships with other people.
You don't have the same kind
of relationship with your accountant
or your boss or your spouse, do you?
Well, I certainly hope not.
And just like that,
the right relationship
between human and AI in a company
is not a one-size-fits-all.
So in the case of Humana,
AI was a recommender
and a human was decision-maker and actor.
In some other examples,
AI might be an evaluator
where a human comes up
with ideas or scenarios,
and AI evaluates the complex implications
and tradeoffs of those ideas
and makes it easy for humans to decide
the best course of action.
In some other examples,
AI might take a more creative role.
It could be an illuminator
where it can take a complex problem
and come up with potential
solutions to that problem
and illuminate some options
that might have been impossible
for humans to see.
Let me give you another example.
During the COVID pandemic,
if you walked into a retail
or grocery store,
you saw that many retailers
were struggling.
Their shelves were empty,
their suppliers were not able
to fulfill the orders,
and with all the uncertainties
of the pandemic,
they simply had no idea how many people
would be walking into what stores,
demanding what products.
Now, to put this in perspective,
this is a problem that's already quite
hard when things are normal.
Retailers have to predict demand
for tens of thousands of products
across thousands of locations
and thousands of suppliers every day
to manage and optimize their inventory.
Add to that the uncertainties of COVID
and the global supply chain disruptions,
and this became 100 times more difficult.
And many retailers were simply paralyzed.
But there were a few who had built
strong foundations with AI
and the human-AI feedback loop
that we talked about.
And these guys were able
to navigate all this uncertainty
much better than others.
They used AI to analyze
tens of billions of data points
on consumer behavior
and global supply chain disruptions
and local government closures and mandates
and traffic on highways
and ocean freight lanes and many,
many other factors
and get a pretty good handle on what
consumers in each unique area
wanted the most,
what would have been feasible,
and for items that were not available,
what substitutions could be made.
But AI alone without the human touch
wouldn't work either.
There were ethical and economic tradeoffs
that had to be considered.
For example, deciding
to bring in a product
that didn't have a good margin
for the retailer
but would really help support
the local community
at their time of need.
After all, AI couldn't quite understand
the uniquely human behavior
of panic-buying toilet paper
or tens of gallons of liquor,
only to be used as hand sanitizer.
It was the combination that was the key.
And the winning companies know this.
They also know that inside
their companies,
there's literally hundreds of these
opportunities for human-AI combination,
and they actively identify
and pursue them.
They think of AI as much more broadly
a means to replace people.
They look inside their organizations
and re-imagine how the biggest challenges
and opportunities of their company
can be addressed
by the combination of human and AI.
And they put in place the right
combination for each unique situation.
Whether it's the recommender
or the evaluator
or the illuminator or optimizer
or many, many other ones.
They build and evolve the feedback loops
that we talked about.
And finally and most importantly,
they don't just throw technology at it.
In fact, this has been
the biggest pitfall of companies
who don't get their return
from their AI investments.
If they overinvest in technology
expecting a piece of tech
to solve all their problems.
But there is no silver bullet.
Technology and automation
can only go so far,
and for every one automation
opportunity inside a company,
there's literally ten for collaboration.
But collaboration's hard.
It requires a new mindset
and doing things differently
than how we've always done it.
And the winning companies
know this, too,
which is why they don't just
invest in technology,
but so much more on human factors,
on their people,
on training and reskilling
and reimagining how their people
and AI work together in new ways.
Inside these companies,
it's not just machines replacing humans.
It's machines and humans working together,
learning from each other.
And when that happens,
the organization's overall rate
of learning increases,
which in turn makes the company
much more agile,
much more resilient,
ready to adapt
and take on any challenge.
It is the human touch
that will bring the best out of AI.
Thank you.
(Applause)